[Music]
foreign
my name is Rob how do I keep my marriage
and other relationships healthy when I
work long hours
all right it's one question Friday
somebody asked a question about marriage
I've been married for a few years I've
been with my wife in a relationship for
10 years plus and it's a pretty great
relationship someone was asking me for
advice on it and I'm going to reference
something that I used to do so basically
I talked about this thing on this pods
basically I've got this new thing I'm
working on and my co-founder and I we
did something interesting that seems
pretty obvious to me but when I
mentioned on the podcast it surprised
some people but basically we kind of
like both had an idea that we wanted to
work on and we were like cool like this
is something I'm working I would like to
work on would you like to work on and he
said yeah whatever and so we got a
little bit of Attraction we go all right
we know this book can work but let's
pump the brakes stop right now and I
want to have a conversation with you and
what I want to know is a bunch of
questions and so I said I sent him the
same questions and then I went and
answered them on my on my own and it
basically outlined what so here's the
categories it was what do I want so
financially I said what I want my
personal net worth to be I said that I
want to have freedom I want the ability
to fly private I want to live in
different cities throughout the year I
want to be present in my future
children's and current wife's life
current life you know what I mean uh I
want to own a bunch of different uh real
estate I want fun and Adventure I want
to work hard but I want to work like a
line me lion meaning I'm willing to work
like in grind for many weeks but then I
want to take three or four weeks off uh
a year or five weeks off a year and I
want to travel the world comfortably I
also said that I care about influence I
said I want to see at the big boys table
and for people to think that I'm really
good at my job and so I just said like
here's like what I want in life then I
we each answered a question of ways that
were uh ways in which we want to get to
where we want to go so basically things
we're willing to do and I said I'm
willing to do this I'm willing to do
this and I'm willing to do this like I'm
not willing to hire 10 000 employees I
don't want that I'm not willing to have
recurring meetings I'm not willing to do
this or that I am willing to work 80
hours a week I am willing to put this
first above every other project I have
things like that and then finally we
said like here's what we want out of
this business we want to aggressively
scale it or that's what I said I want to
aggressively scale it I want to hit 100
million dollars in Revenue in x amount
of years like so anyway really specific
and then he answered this on his own and
we came back together and we said all
right let's see where we aligned and
where we don't align because I want to
figure out right away if there's any
deal breakers and in fact this is what I
do did when I sold my company I said um
have a spot wanted to buy us and I go
they sent me a cold email and they go
hey we want to talk about partnership
and I was like I don't know what
partnership means does that mean you
want to buy us just tell me right away
and they said yeah we want to buy you I
said cool here's a Google doc and it I
list out all the reasons why you don't
want to buy us and where we stink if
that list is okay with you talk to me
again
and so they said yeah we're okay with
everything on this list it's none of
it's that bad and we said all right cool
let's keep talking and so anyway my
point is is I've learned with
relationships throughout the years
particularly like marriages and business
relationships and with my partner or
HubSpot you want to get the difficult
conversations out the way early on
because that will literally save you a
decade of heartache and with my marriage
I did the same thing
this data is wrong every freaking time
have you heard of HubSpot
HubSpot is a CRM platform where
everything is fully integrated well I
can see the client's whole history calls
support tickets emails and here's a test
from three days ago I totally missed
HubSpot grow better
so my wife and I
sounds kind of lame because I don't want
it to sound that my like business is so
important to me that it like permutates
into like my marriage but in a way it
kind of does but basically
bye
two months or three months into dating I
was like hey just so you know or maybe
it was six months I was like just you
know like I I see us going places and
like being together for a very long time
and potentially marriage is that what
you see and she was like yeah I was like
oh awesome we're on the same page um and
then we actually outlined you know how
like when people say they're like yeah I
want to like have a nice house with kids
and all this stuff and I was like all
right let's get really specific tell me
how many kids do you think you want you
don't need to like tell me you want
exactly three kids but like give me a
ballpark like where your intentions are
now and I know they might change but uh
give me like a ballpark on where they
are okay great now how much money do you
want to make each year okay cool where
do you want to live oh you want to live
here let's go in Zillow right now oh
that house is eight million dollars so
let's work backwards to like where how
much that how we're gonna afford that
house uh great so we understand like
where we want to be or you know
financially let's talk about what we're
willing to sacrifice in order to get
that and we listed out all those things
it's like look for my uh 20s business is
gonna come before uh like relationships
so like meaning there's going to be a
lot of times that I'm not going to be
around when you need me but that's
because I'm gonna be dedicating a lot of
time in order to get this other goal
that we have that we're going to have in
our 30s things like that and so we
really just outlined like very
specifically where we wanted to be in 10
20 and 30 years and we did it exactly
like a business where it was like here's
where we want to go specifically like
here's how much money we want how many
kids we want the type of Lifestyle we
want the type of family we want in our
life
um if we wanted to raise them religious
or not religious like all this stuff and
of course we knew it will change as we
grow and get more information but anyway
we did that to get that hard stuff out
of the way another thing that we do
which is like kind of lame but you know
how a company has okrs uh which stands
for
objectives and key results and like
you're supposed to set those quarterly
we and annually you have like an annual
Target and then like quarterly like
benchmarks we do that for our life and
so we have an adventure one we have a
like relationship one
we have a financial one and we have a um
a
a physical fitness one where it's like
all right here's where we like here's
what we want to do like for our health
here's what we want to the trips that we
want to take here's we want to be
financially here's the um ways that we
want to like give back to our family and
spend time with them and we actually do
these check-ins once a week
um I use this journal that uh my friend
started her name's Kat uh it's called Uh
uh best self coat and she's got this
relationship journal and for the longest
time
um we still do it but we uh would meet
once a week on Friday and we would
document where we are according to our
goals and
it's pretty successful so anyway
um that's how I look at my marriage I
take it like I do two things that are
kind of odd but I think it works is I we
kind of operate it like a business of
course there's like
I remember when we were getting married
you have to like meet with the priest
ahead of time and we were like yeah we
have the same values we have the same
this and he was like well do you guys
love each other and we're like yeah dude
obviously like of course so like I want
to acknowledge that like this sounds
like really regimented but there's like
all that love and the important stuff is
totally obviously there that's the most
important thing but like logistically we
do a really good job of like outlining
what we want to achieve together as a
family for the next quarter and the next
year in the next 10 years
um and then we do a really good job of
like checking in weekly and monthly to
discussing like are we happy with how
things are going what do we need to
change and things like that and I think
it works really well like learning how
to do these having these conversations
that was actually kind of hard but I
think it works so that's my tips for
successful marriage but honestly a
successful in a relationship I've got a
lot of relationships Sean and I
you know the less popular co-host of
this podcast uh him and I have had a
relationship for
uh 10 plus years now and it's fairly
harmonious but it's very harmonious
um a bunch of my co-workers I've worked
with now for six seven eight nine ten
years
um
so it mostly works pretty good
um these types of check-ins and
conversations so anyway that's my
small amount of tips for having a good
marriage
[Music]